[Musik]
willkommen bei Bild Deutschland ist am
Limit Millionen Deutsche verlieren
gerade an Wohlstand wegen der
Energiekrise und mitten in dieser
tiefsten Krise in Deutschland so viele
Flüchtlinge auf wie seit 2015 nicht mehr
wir stellen hier die einfache Frage wie
soll das gehen können wir uns das
leisten die richtigen Fragen an Merkels
Infrastrukturminister andreas Scheuer an
Ursula Engelen Käfer die langjährige DGB
Vize-Chefin und jetzt Vizepräsidentin
des Sozialverbands Deutschlands Bernd
Lucke
Ökonomieprofessor Mitgründer und Ex-Chef
der AFD heute Chef der kleinen Partei
der Liberalen konservativen Reformer und
Frank Schaeffler
fdp-bundestagsabgeordneter der als
euro-rebell bekannt wurde außerdem Annas
modermani bei uns der durch ein Foto
weltberühmt wurde ein selfie nämlich mit
Angela Merkel und heute hilft er
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen mit seiner
ukrainischen Freundin das ist das Foto
noch mal hier und die richtigen Fragen
auch an den Ex özykanzler Sebastian Kurz
mit dem ich vor dieser Sendung
gesprochen habe und der die deutsche
Flüchtlingspolitik hart kritisiert
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild Herr
Lucke wir haben die Sendung Deutschland
am Limit genannt wie dicht ist
Deutschland in dieser Energie-
ja wir sind ganz bestimmt in einer
ausgesprochen dramatischen Lage was die
Leistungsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
betrifft auch in Bezug auf die sozialen
Umstände über die ich jetzt vielleicht
weniger spreche weil ich denke das macht
dann Frau Engel den Käfer aber das ist
natürlich auch ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt
noch dieser ganzen energiepreistrise
aber in Bezug auf die Wirtschaft ist es
eben so dass wir eine so enorme Erhöhung
von Energiepreisen haben dass das für
viele Unternehmen inzwischen Existenz
bedrohend wird schon in der Finanzkrise
stand Deutschland wir haben Abgrund
Finanzminister Peer Steinbrück hat das
damals gesagt wir haben in der Abgrund
geschaut sie hat das damals so
umgetrieben dass sie eine Partei
gegründet haben damals mit gegründet
haben die AFD ist die Situation jetzt
dramatischer als damals also moment mal
die die AFD habe ich sehr viel später
gegründet nämlich nicht bei der
Finanzkrise sondern damals in der Stadt
Schuldenkrise 2013 ganz genau 2009 Sonne
2013 vier Jahre später die Situation ist
heute aber eine ganz andere damals
drohten staatsinsolvenzen überall in der
Eurozone Deutschland war aber
ausgesprochen stark hatte sich erholt
von der Finanzkrise war leistungsfähig
und war im Begriff große
wirtschaftszusagen für eben die
bedrohten von staatsinsolvenzbedrohten
Euro Staaten zu machen heute sind wir
diejenigen die vielleicht von dieser
Energiekrise innerhalb der Europäischen
Union am schwersten getroffen sind aber
diese enorme Abhängigkeit von russischer
Energie haben also
das ist natürlich für unsere
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit ein
deutlich stärkere bedrohungern vor allem
den Käfer sie vertreten sozusagen die
sozialen Schwächsten in Funktionen und
in ihrem ganzen Leben haben sie genau
das gemacht das gewerktschafterin wie
viel Millionen Deutsche sind im Moment
schon überm Limit
also wir haben eine weitere Steigerung
der Armutsquote also der
Armutsgefährdung für Menschen die
weniger als 60 Prozent des mittleren
Einkommens verdienen und das ist sehr
schwer in unserem Land damit zu leben
das geht weiter fort und wir haben etwa
eine noch höhere Rate der
Armutsgefährdung für Kinder das ist
unsere Zukunft und genau darum geht es
dass es die Menschen die wenig haben am
meisten trifft sei das die Wohnungskrise
die Mieten Krise die Energiekrise gerade
Menschen die wenig haben die am Limit
sind sozusagen auch an Ihrem
persönlichen Limit oder darunter schon
in der armutspirale die wohnen meistens
in den Wohnungen die am wenigsten
energetisch zu sichern sind und zu
verbessern sind die also sehr stark
betroffen sind die müssen laufend die
Preise in den Supermärkten bezahlen und
zwar ständig Erhöhungen bezahlen und
gleichzeitig werden die Maßnahmen die in
die Wege geleitet wurden als nicht
ausreichend angesehen was auch der Fall
ist und die neuen die jetzt kommen
sollen werden zur redet da warten wir
noch drauf auf dieses sogenannte dritte
entlastungs-
für viele Menschen wichtig ist das lange
Warten Frau Engeln Käfer scheuer jetzt
reden wir über Deutschland am Limit er
Lucke Frau engeling Käfer immer aus
jeweiligen Perspektiven geschildert wie
dicht am Limit Deutschland bereits ist
oder viele Millionen eben darüber hinweg
die Regierung die wünscht man sich jetzt
ganz stark handlungsfähig ist die auch
am Limit Ihrem Empfinden nach
ja das können wir heute noch intensiv
diskutieren und vielen einzelnen Themen
ich sag mal grundsätzlich Deutschland
ist mittlerweile im dauerkrisenmodus ein
paar Krisen haben wir uns nicht
ausgesucht zum Beispiel die corona-krise
oder auch den Krieg in der Ukraine die
Sanktionen die wir zurecht positioniert
haben gegen den Aggressor Russland die
schlagen jetzt doppelt auf den
erfolgreichste Land in Europa zurück
Exportweltmeister Logistik Weltmeister
Industrieland und wir sind natürlich
nicht allein auf der Welt weil wir in
den letzten Jahren natürlich Zulieferung
gebraucht haben deswegen haben wir auch
günstige produzieren können unter
Wohlstand ist grundsätzlich gewachsen
aber Frau engeling Käfer hat natürlich
recht dass mit der Inflation einer
nächsten Krise diese Regierung zu wenig
dagegen steuert um diese Preisspirale zu
durchbrechen und tut aktuell nicht alles
um unseren Wohlstand zu erhalten also
wir klares Jahr tut nicht alles dafür
und vor allem vor allem die 200
Milliarden die wir ja in dieser Woche
auch noch
diskutieren sind ja nur wieder ein ein
Heftpflaster auf diese brüchige
Situation wir müssen ja viel viel früher
anfangen beispielsweise bei einer
Energie nämlich beider Quelle bei der
Infrastruktur um zeige ich mal die
Kosten auch in den Griff zu bekommen und
wenn wir jetzt diese
Regierungsentscheidung haben dass wir
ein Monat eine Zuschuss bekommen und die
Rechnungen übernommen werden dann kommt
ja diese gaspreisbremse erst nach der
Heizperiode im März oder April ich finde
das nicht richtig ich denke dass wir
stark sind als Deutschland aber dass wir
jetzt eine schwache Regierung haben
schwache Regierung sind sie mit
angesprochen Schaeffler auch wenn sie
eins der Rebell in der FDP waren jetzt
regieren sie eben mit denen und stimmen
auch mit der FDP und stimmen auch mit
den Grünen im übrigen und Frau Engeln
Käfers Kanzler Scholz sie vertreten also
hier in der Runde die Regierungspolitik
und sie regieren schwach sagt der
Scheuer
naja das muss er als Opposition
ein ich glaube ist natürlich eine sehr
sehr schwierige Situation scheuert dass
gerade angesprochen Ukraine Krieg
Pandemie aber auch wegen dieser
all das ist natürlich ein ökonomisch ich
glaube das haben in den 16 Jahren Angela
Merkel haben wir nicht so eine
Zusammenhaltung von Krisen erlebt wie
wir das aktuell erleben und jetzt geht
es darum eben darauf entschlossen zu
reagieren und da hat der Kanzler ja
heute eine Machtwort gesprochen was sie
Verlängerung der Atomkraftwerke betrifft
und das ja auch gute und richtig so denn
da hat er Habeck ja jetzt über Monate
die Sache verzögert so der Knöpfe ich
gleich diese Entscheidung doch
vorsichtig das also entschieden hat es
ist noch so frisch die Entscheidung über
alle drei Atomkraftwerke nämlich auch
das Atomkraftwerke Niedersachsen Emsland
auch das soll also bis April bis ins
hinein nun laufen hat der Kanzler heute
einmal auf den Tisch gehauen und hat das
per Machtwort sozusagen per
Richtlinienkompetenz entschieden das
heißt die Grünen haben ab jetzt da
nichts mehr zu melden in ihrer Region
der Kanzler zieht das mit Ihnen durch
nein die Grünen werden das natürlich
mittragen davon gehe ich mal aus als
staatsfragende Partei aber klar ist
natürlich das hätte viel früher laufen
müssen denn wir haben ja schon länger
ein Problem nicht nur um Gaspreis
sondern auch im Strompreis und das dass
das jetzt so lange gedauert hat ist eben
auch an Herrn da müssen wir noch mal
ganz kurz einhalten glauben sie das auch
Herr scheuer bisher gibt es noch ganz
wenige Reaktionen erst von den Grünen
das heißt ja der Schäffler sagt jetzt
sie werden das mittragen die haben am
Wochenende nämlich das war genau gestern
und vorgestern das Gegenteil auf ihren
Parteitag beschlossen und diskutiert
schaut euch das Wochenende an ich weiß
nicht ob jetzt die Grünen noch etwas
ausnüchternd unterwegs sind von diesen
Parteitag schaut euch die Reden an woher
habe lange argumentiert hat dass der
weiterbetriebe im Emsland eben nicht gut
ist und jetzt ein paar Stunden später
kommt in Wirklichkeit die Ernüchterung
also wir werden sehen ich glaube
Donnerstag Entscheidung stehen im
Deutschen Bundestag da werde ich mal
stimmt Moment Moment
wo sich jetzt der Schäffler so freut
über diese Entscheidung die ist nicht
nicht im Grundsatz nämlich die
nachhaltige denn diese mal ganz einer
Meinung bis April also das Laufen sie
hätten das Laufen bis April ist jetzt
natürlich der Schäffler muss das auch
gut heißen natürlich auch ein Teil Mini
kleiner Erfolg für Christian Lindner
aber Fakt ist dass die Energiekrise ja
weit über den April geht das immer
wieder
diesen Vorschlag den jetzt herr Scholz
ausgedrückt hat mit Richtlinienkompetenz
nach ein paar Stunden des grünen
Parteitags für eben zu kurz gesprochen
der Scheuer mit seiner mit seiner
cdu/csu läuft lässt sie schön auflaufen
bzw die Grünen die kriegen sie doch nie
dazu dass die diesen macht beschlossen
Opposition auch an ihre Verantwortung
nicht also ich sag mal für die grüne ist
das natürlich ein großer Schritt aber
der reicht natürlich nicht aus natürlich
völlig klar aber das heißt sie brauchen
zum Regieren sie appellieren jetzt an
die cdu/cs
zum Regieren jetzt unbedingt
nach dieser Entscheidung sagen sie schon
das reicht nicht das sieht man den
Zustand der Koalition ist völlig klar
hätten wir den Vorschlag von Friedrich
Merz aus März
umgesetzt dass wir Nord Stream ein
sofort abgeschaltet hätten dann hätten
wir schon im Sommer die Katastrophe ich
will nur sagen auch die Opposition hat
eine gewisse Verantwortung in diesem
Land gewisse Dinge auch mit
durchzusetzen und da appelliere ich an
der Union beispielsweise wir haben
verteidigungsetagen
jetzt haben wir dieses Machtwort und die
Grünen werden möglicherweise da nicht
zustimmen kann mir auch verstehen die
haben gerade auf ihren Parteitag das
Gegenteil beschlossen jetzt sagt der
Scheuer trägt er auch nicht mit dann
steht hier FDP mit ihrem Kanzler alleine
und Sie verlieren die Abstimmung im
Bundestag also ich glaube wir sollten
hier ein bisschen abrüsten verbal denn
wir sind in das ganze Desaster alle
gemeinsam gekommen nicht denn wer hat
die Entscheidungen getroffen in der
Vergangenheit dass wir jetzt in dieser
Abhängigkeit sind ich glaube da können
wir uns alle an die eigene Nase fassen
und deshalb alle sage ich alle naja der
andere weniger aber deshalb wäre es
jetzt wichtig dass wir das Dilemma nicht
weiter fortführen denn es geht ja um die
Menschen und es geht um die Wirtschaft
beides und auch die Wirtschaft hat ja
Arbeitsplätze die wiederum wichtig sind
für die Entwicklung unserer Wirtschaft
und für das was Menschen an Wohlstand
oder eben an Einkommen daraus ziehen und
später als Rente und deshalb dürfen wir
das nicht blockieren sondern da haben
alle die verantwortlich
ganz kurz ich war Stopp ich war bei der
Momentum
sie hat natürlich Recht alle haben den
Atomausstieg mit beschlossen egal in
welchen regierungskonstellationen waren
alle dafür Topmanager Gewerkschaftler
alle waren dafür so aber unser Thema ist
ja wir müssen jetzt in einer neuen Lage
Politik machen die neue Lage hat sich
mit dem 24 Februar verändert das ist der
entscheidende Punkt
für April ein
Energiesicherheit Käfer hat ein ganz
wichtigen Satz gesagt und der war es
geht doch hier um die Menschen es geht
um unseren Wohlstand und es geht um
unsere
ist das tatsächlich ihr Eindruck nach
jetzt ja bald irgendwie einem Jahr
Regierung das ist hier tatsächlich um
die Menschen geht um die Bürger geht um
die Wirtschaft geht es geht bei den
Grünen ja ganz offenbar um eine
parteitagsentscheidung um alte grünen
Biografie es geht darum hierbei Herrn
scheuer ob man das jetzt strategisch
damit trägt im Bundestag ja oder nein
aber jetzt tatsächlich die Menschen und
um den Wohlstand also ich muss schon
sagen mich hat das bisschen konzerniert
jetzt gerade dieser Austausch hier weil
ich denke dieses kleinen kleinen was ich
jetzt hier am Tisch so abgespielt hat ja
bei einer solch existenziellen Krise wie
wir sie haben da habe ich wenig
Verständnis dafür und ehrlich gesagt ich
verstehe auch die Lesart nicht nicht so
ganz die von dieser Richtlinien
Kompetenz Entscheidung des des
Bundeskanzlers dass man jetzt sagt die
die Grünen haben da Federn gelassen also
ich sehe es ehrlich gesagt ganz ganz
anders die Grünen haben von Anfang an
gesagt zwei Atomkraftwerke sollen noch
drei Monate laufen die FDP hat gesagt
drei Atomkraftwerke sollen noch laufen
aber bis 2024 jetzt sagt der
Bundeskanzler gutes soll der
Atomkraftwerke noch drei Monate laufen
also eigentlich ist das für die Grünen
eine Sache war es nicht das zu
akzeptieren finde ich ist eine
Kleinigkeit für die Grünen aber die FDP
hat sich nicht durchgesetzt so wie es
mir scheiße sie würden sagen
der entscheidenden Frage wird es neue
Brennstäbe geben die neuen brennt nicht
geben und solange wir diese neuen
Brennstoff nicht ist diese ganze Energie
Problematik die mit den Atomkraftwerken
eine Teillösung eine bescheidene kleine
Teillösung haben könnte nicht gelöst das
Problem ist nach wie vor vollständig
ungelöst liegt violent auf dem Tisch und
die Regierung ja wie hat sich immer auf
einen Formel Kompromiss geeinigt wo die
FDP jetzt enttäuschender Weise
augenscheinlich dem zustimmen wird
eigentlich finde ich herr Schäffler die
FDP müsste das Ablehnen nämlich zu sagen
das ist viel zu wenig
was bedeutet das denn jetzt für die
Ökologie was bedeutet das für die
Wirtschaft in Deutschland diese sage ich
jetzt mal mit meinen Worten sie
übersetzt diese Weichei Entscheidung des
Kanzlers die viel zu wenig ist in ihren
Augen die bedeutet nach meinem
Dafürhalten dass man die eigentlichen
Probleme noch nicht erkannt hat du wirst
eigentliche Problem ist gar nicht die
Tatsache dass wir im Augenblick
Schwierigkeiten mit der Gasversorgung
haben weil Russland einen
unzuverlässiger Lieferant ist und und
dass die Preise so sehr in die Höhe
gegangen sind sondern dass viel tiefer
liegende Problem ist dass noch viel
schlimmere Dinge auf uns zukommen können
ich meine wir haben diese Angriffe jetzt
gehabt auf die nordstream Leitungen wer
kann uns denn zusichern oder wer hat ein
Konzept für das mögliche Szenario das
andere erdgaspipelines die aus Norwegen
kommen die aus Aserbaidschan kommen die
aus Marokko kommen im Laufe des Winters
nicht möglicherweise auch solchen
Angriffen ausgesetzt sind und plötzlich
haben wir eine viel schlimmere
gasmangellager als das was diese famose
graspreiskommission zugrunde gelegt aber
also dass ich noch die eigentlichen
Probleme das richtig und das in einer
weiteren Verschärfung der Lage rechnen
deshalb möchte ich sehe nicht dass die
Regionen müssen wir umstellen bitte Herr
von Lucke oder
hallo das war letzte Woche wir müssen
umstellen und nicht nur über Gas und
Strom sondern auch über erneuerbare
Energien und wir können dir das nicht
alles immer weiter aufschieben
gerade in Krisen können wir eine
Veränderung Verlassen
der rechnet mit Ihnen ab und er sagt das
ist heute nur Verschleierung sie haben
sich Zeit gekauft es bringt überhaupt
nichts die Wirtschaft rockt weiter
runter und sie stehen im Frühjahr
derselben Entscheidung wieder ist
natürlich sehr verkürzt dargestellt denn
die Situation war ja im Frühjahr eine
völlig andere oder im Sommer ja da hat
Herr Habeck noch gesagt es gibt
überhaupt keine Verlängerung dann hat er
gesagt es gibt nur eine
notfallverlängerung also wenn gar nichts
anderes geht das ja nur sie lassen sich
ja jetzt feiern für den Beschluss ich
lasse mir überhaupt nicht feiern sondern
ich halte das für eine richtige und
staatspolitische Entscheidung die jetzt
getroffen wurde die man jetzt erstmal
positiv zur Kenntnis nehmen kann und
nicht weiter verlängert und nicht erst
mal nicht weiterfahren ich finde da muss
natürlich auch darüber sprechen wie es
im nächsten Winter weitergeht also der
jetzige Winter ist ja der Eine aber
warum sollen die Strompreise eigentlich
sinken die werden nicht sinken sondern
die werden auf dem Niveau bleiben und
deshalb muss es darum gehen alles
mögliche auch ins Netz zu nehmen da
gehören die Atomkraftwerke dazu da
gehören die Kohlekraftwerke dazu da
gehören aber auch die Braunkohle
waren Energien bitte bitte erneuerbar
aber wir brauchen nicht ganz in Abrede
stellen sondern da müssen wir
weitermachen wegen Strom und das kriegen
sie natürlich nur mit Atomkraft mit
kernkranz also ich glaube noch mal eine
wir waren jetzt nicht dem kleinen wir
waren schon sehr sehr grundsätzlich und
jeder vielleicht verbuchen wir das jetzt
mal ist für die Erneuerbaren egal in
welcher Stärke im Norden er dem Wind äh
in meiner Heimat eher Wasserkraft und
Regen also Sonnenkraft und verbuchen wir
das einmal dass das jeder will wir
brauchen auch den Umstieg und diese
Energiewende trotzdem brauchen wir für
die Leistungsfähigkeit unserer
Wirtschaft für
Entstehen des deutschen Mittelstandes
und die Quittung war ja in Niedersachsen
für die FDP mit diesem Wahlergebnis das
ist auch Wirtschaften mit vielen
Arbeitsplätzen Frau engeling Käfer zu
guten Löhnen möglich weiterhin möglich
ist in Deutschland und ich kenne genug
die Arbeit einstellen weil sie sagen mit
diesen Strompreisen können wir nicht
mehr Wirtschaften die gehen frei nach
Harbig nicht in die Insolvenz sondern
die hören einfach zum Arbeiten auf ob
das die Gärtnerei ist oder ein
siliziumwerk bei mir im Wahlkreis der
letzte deutsche siliziumhersteller der
regional Lieferdienst Chemiedreieck das
tut mir indem sie mit
Massenarbeitslosigkeit der Lücke
im Augenblick nicht ja wir haben
Arbeitskräftemangel in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland sind ganz
großes fundamentales Problem was haben
aber ich muss noch mal was zu den
erneuerbaren Sachen erstens hat der
Scheffler schon völlig zu Recht gesagt
es geht ja um die grundlastfähigkeit und
die Erneuerbaren sind nicht
grundlastfähig aber wir dürfen auch die
das quantitative da nicht aus den Augen
verlieren die Erneuerbaren die wir jetzt
seit 15 waren 20 Jahren oder irgend
sowas ähnliches ausgebaut haben tragen
zur Zeit zum
Energiebedarf für unsere Deutschland 16
% 1 6 ja und die Serie 84%
84 Prozent die sich unglaublich stark
verteuert haben und da kann man nicht
immer die Öffentlichkeit nass führen
indem man sagt ja wir machen jetzt die
Energiewende und dann braucht man diese
84% eigentlich nicht sondern wir blasen
unter 16% und wie auch auf 100 % in
dieser Zeit überhaupt nicht wollen sie
in dieser Runde begrüßen sie sind von
uns allen am kürzesten in Deutschland
bisher sie sind vor ja 2015 zu uns
gekommen aus Syrien nach Deutschland
wenn Sie all das mitbekommen wenn sie
auch im Moment mitbekommen wo
Deutschland gerade steht haben Sie das
Gefühl sie sind da in ein Land gekommen
was sich ja am Abgrund befindet was
gerade abstürzt abschmiert also
natürlich gibt es sehr viele Probleme
die schon häufig ist auch natürlich
wieder kombinierst du raus von dem
corona-pandemie und dann kommt jetzt
noch mal der Krieg in der Ukraine das
bedeutet betrifft ja uns alle nicht nur
in der Ukraine und ich habe es natürlich
klare Meinung dass das dass die Menschen
hier schon was tun können und wir stehen
auf die Seite der Ukraine wir sind dabei
bei der Unterstützung und wenn ich höre
wie viele Probleme gerade darüber
diskutiert wird ich mache mir einfach
hoffen und dass wir das Handy kriegen
also vor dem Krieg in der Ukraine wir
haben natürlich erstes Mal davon gehört
dass in der Ukraine die Menschen also
erstmal wenn wir über Flüchtlingspolitik
natürlich ähm also reden die Menschen
also Deutschland sagt ja zwei Jahren
also ein paar Monate vor dem Krieg in
der Ukraine der beginnen wir haben ja
keine Kapazität es ist mal sprechen wir
gleich drüber ganz kurz noch einmal auch
mit ihnen über das Energiepreis Thema
wie hoch ist aktuell ihre Stromrechnung
ihre Gasrechnung macht Ihnen das zu
schaffen zahlen Sie die selber wird also
übernommen ich bezahle die selber kriege
ich noch Bafög aber das ist echt wenig
ich mache mir natürlich auch Sorge wie
es wie ich meine Oberdorf Winter mal
drüber komme und ja im Supermarkt ich
kann viele Produkte mir ich selber nicht
mehr leisten
ich kann mir nicht gesunde ernähren wie
früher ich habe immer so vielleicht sag
ich mal lachsfisch gegessen und ich habe
versucht mich Gesundes zu ernähren heute
ist unbezahlbar dass ich ich werde das
nicht noch mal in meinem Kühlschrank
vielleicht wieder haben ja genau das ist
es nämlich nicht das hier die
Entlastungen nicht ausreichen für die
Menschen damit sie überhaupt über die
Runden kommen und da ist für mich zum
Beispiel ganz wichtig die Frage der Gas
und Strompreis Bremsen und die
Auseinandersetzungen die wir uns hier
leisten erst einmal mit dieser
gasumlage die ja katastrophal war was
ich auch herausgestellt hat wie viel
Zeit haben wir damit vertan und die
Menschen im Grunde genommen in die Irre
geschickt und jetzt die Frage der
gaspreisbremse was haben wir denn im
Dezember gibt es dann die Einmalzahlung
und die gasbremse soll es dann erst
geben wenn die Wintersaison vorbei ist
das ist doch nicht mehr nachvollziehbar
hört auch einen strombremse nicht nur
eine gaspreisbremse auch hat das
natürlich im Wesentlich gemacht um das
jetzt schnell auf die Straße zu bringen
ja hätte man jetzt erstmal
das gemacht was jetzt im Frühjahr gilt
das wäre gar nicht möglich gewesen sind
marktwirtschaftlich durchgehen muss doch
das die Decke gehen ist das eigentlich
die falsche Baustelle also ich glaube
man muss einfach das Energieangebot
erhöhen und so wir müssen auf der
anderen Seite auch versuchen eine eine
Fiskalpolitik zu betreiben und eine
Geldpolitik zu betreiben die
letztendlich die Inflation bekämpft was
den Finanzminister
die Politik der EZB die ist seit 10 15
Jahren die Finanzminister und sagen
jetzt bei der Kritik von Frau engeling
liefern nein gut das machen wir jetzt
halt so weil es musste schnell gehen wir
ja darauf dass wir den Laden auch noch
finanziell zusammenhalten denn gerade
nicht die FDP nicht gäbe dann gibt's
noch mehr genau da wäre es wesentlich
schlimmer grüner und SPD hätten längst
weil
wir reden über eine
Minuten weil der Regierungsvertreter ich
verstehe ja dass sie jetzt nicht jeden
grünen Parteitagsbeschluss hier mit
vertreten können aber die Grundlinien
ihrer Politik verkaufen sie nach dem
Motto musste halt schnell gehen und
dafür hauen wir die Milliarden aus
einzige der einzige Euro Rebell ich
glaube da waren sie sich sehr nah in der
Zeit der damals das Geld zusammen nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein also
Fakt ist schon das jetzt die Hilfe
schnell ankommen muss
200 Milliarden nein wofür und
Dimensionen wie ist die Zeitdimensionen
die Leute werden rebellisch zurecht denn
die müssen ja jede Woche oder jeden alle
paar Tage die hohen Rechnungen bezahlen
Abschläge die haben die Abschläge auf
dem Tisch liegen die wollen doch in
ihren Wohnungen bleiben und ähm
Finanzminister nicht die Orientierung am
hohen Erdgaspreis genau das ist der
Punkt
Milliarden zusammenhalten also das
müssen wir mal erklären die gesamten
Importe der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
an Öl und Gas im Jahre 2021 beliefen
sich auf 80 Milliarden Euro 80
Milliarden davon kam 40% aus Russland
das macht 32 Milliarden sie geben jetzt
200 Milliarden aus um diese 32
Milliarden die war letztes Jahr
ausgegeben haben zu verbilligen
irgendwie das geht für mich
also 200 Milliarden ist
200 Milliarden sollen dafür bewilligt
werden dass man diese gaspreisbremse
bekommt die ich im übrigen im Grundsatz
für richtig finde im Detail ist da mal
falsch aber grundsätzlich richtig ja
aber es sind 200 Milliarden Euro für
eine Menge an Importen die uns im
letzten Jahr 32 Euro
was ist denn daran die Milliarden
zusammenhalten ich meine das ist ein
Vielfaches von dem was wir letztes Jahr
ausgegeben haben was jetzt alles auf
Kosten des Steuerzahlers oder ist
künftigen Steuerzahler Verschuldung
finanziert werden wird finanzierbar alle
was wir jetzt machen ist dass wir den
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds einer
kreditermächtigung über 200 Milliarden
geben ob die dann am Ende genutzt werden
das wird man erst noch sehen müssen ja
das ist wie
bei den Retter
haben wir den Wirtschaft stabilisierungs
vor ja auch genutzt um Industrien zu
retten aber doch
also Stichwort Lufthansa Lufthansa hat
am Ende seine Hilfen wieder
zurückgezahlt ja also das heißt noch
nicht dass wir das tatsächlich in dieser
Form nutzen werden und dass wir das
dafür einsetzen werden es zu 100% zur
erdgasabsenkung zum Preis Absenkung
nutzen werden sondern dass ein
Instrument das uns jetzt durch diese
Krise führen soll das ist das Ziel ja
aber das ist toll
das wird man sehen das hängt ein
bisschen vom Verleiher das heißt also
ja aber wir sind doch jetzt in einer
Situation wo wir nur auf Sicht fahren
können wir haben den die
corona-situation wir haben Ukraine wir
wissen nicht wie der Krieg weiter
verläuft und es ist halt ein
gigantisches Paket dass sie dass sie da
unter den Weihnachtsbaum legen und am
Ende
Verantwortung Wörter auch dass man sage
ich mal im Blick auf diese Krise ein
bisschen auf Sicht fährt und jetzt nicht
ist schon alle Antworten parat hat wie
der wie der Krieg in der Ukraine
weitergeht das wissen wir doch heute
nicht welche Maßnahmen Herr Putin noch
ergreift um unsere Energie Situation
weiter ja damit können Sie jede damit
können sie ja jede
Regierungsentscheidung begründen dass
man da sie einigen kann weil keine
Ahnung was wir ja diesen Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds um uns darauf
vorzubereiten das ist das Ziel aber Herr
Scheffler fahren sie mich ein bisschen
zu sehr auf sehr sehr kurze Sicht also
wenn
einmal in der Ukraine Ende Februar
erfolgreich
ja eine Woche am 23 September eine Woche
bevor die Heizperiode begann da hat die
Regierung plötzlich gesagt also und wenn
ich nicht mehr weiter weiß dann kann man
Kommission und die musste dann schon
alles aber
wie weh tut das sich von dem ehemaligen
afd-gründer das erklären zu müssen von
dem Ökonomieprofessor in dieser Phase
und sie an den meisten Punkten auch noch
hier sitzen und sagen ja Mist jetzt hat
er gerade recht ja
ich kenne ja nun auch ein bisschen die
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge und frage
mich auch warum nicht früher
agiert worden ist warum man nicht
rechtzeitig der der Einmarsch war am 24
februar und es war schon nach relativ
kurzer Zeit klar wie es weitergehen
würde die Abhängigkeit vom russischen
Gas ist schon lange bekannt das ist ja
unser besonderes Dilemma in der EU die
ist in die anderen Länder egal
glücklicherweise so nicht haben das
haben wir an der Backe kleben weil wir
so lange falsch entschieden haben wollen
aber alle gemeinsam
ins Gas begonnen ja das ist das Thema
also tut man mal nicht so als ob einige
das schon zurecht gesehen hätten und
gewarnt hätten da aber wir müssen jetzt
wissen das Wort
verbindet man historisch mit Stopp
diesen diesen Debattenbeitrag gab schon
Jahre zuvor wo wir argumentiert haben
dieser Weg ins Gas dieser Marsch ins Gas
ist deswegen um natürlich den Ausbau der
regenerativen anzusteuern aber vor allem
ideologisch und da würde mich heute
interessieren wie Herr Trittin der Chef
Ideologien
gute Formulierung
es war ein ein feststehender Begriff in
einer Debatte wo wir die rot-grün
kritisiert haben an dieser Stelle weil
es da falsche Weg ist aber sei es darum
wir haben ja neue Zeiten mittlerweile
herr Schäffler der Kollege
weil ich weiß wie er denkt letztendlich
was die Naivität von Angela Merkel in
dieser Politik ja das ist das Problem
ist
weiter fertig
also das bringt uns auch
gesagt wir müssen das Angebot an
Energieträgern erhöhen das heißt wir
brauchen wir brauchen einen neuen
brennstrebenkraftwerken ja das
möglicherweise nicht kriegen wir an wir
brauchen mehr braunkohleutzung wir
müssen wahrscheinlich eben nicht
aussteigen aus der Kohle sondern wir
müssen das Kohlendioxid auffangen
abscheiden einlagern also Karben capture
Stores ist der Fachausdruck nicht wahr
das heißt wir müssen Kohle gerade
ausbauen damit Ihr unabhängiger werden
von von Energie
und wir brauchen natürlich auch die
Erneuerbaren das ist ganz schlimm
aber nicht kommt wenn bei all dem die
Grünen immer der Klotz am Bein sind
werden sie dann trotzdem kostet es was
es wolle schlecht weiter regieren oder
werden sie die Koalition verlassen die
Grünen werden sich denn Realitäten
ausstellen da bin ich ziemlich sicher
haben Sie ja jetzt bis gerade selber
kritisiert haben nicht gemacht weil
erstmal nur bis früher gesagt
aber es geht Herr Scheffler ganz kurz
gewinnen sich daraus aber im Frühjahr
ist es zu spät und Brennelemente zu
bestellen das ist ja genau das verzögert
dann wieder alles also wir müssen
mehrere Dinge tun wir müssen den Rückbau
der abgeschalteten Atomkraftwerke
stoppen danke hat nicht geklappt bisher
ja aber das muss man natürlich wir
müssen gott sei dank der Druck der Druck
auf die grün wird natürlich groß sein
wer weiß wenn wir einen harten Winter
bekommen dann wird sich diese Frage im
Dezember ganz neu stellen damit ich
ziemlich sicher dass Herr Harbig dann
wieder sich bewegen wird und dann glaube
ich werden wir uns da in dieser Frage
auch durchsetzen und wir brauchen
natürlich auch Schiefer Gasförderung in
Deutschland ist ja totaler Quatsch dass
wir Schiefergas aus den USA importieren
aber in Deutschland lassen wir es nicht
aber wenn all das nicht kommt das müssen
wir noch einmal final klären ist das
dann weil es geht ja hier um die Frage
nicht von irgendwie parteistrategie
sondern darum was den Menschen hilft was
unseren Wohlstand das haben alle Lager
ja
oder Mani da sagen oder Mani mit seiner
Partnerin weniger an Nebenkosten zahlt
geht es nur nicht um ein Paket erneut
als Heftpflaster auf dem Weg zur auf dem
Tisch zu stellen sondern die an der
Quelle des Angebots so wenn das nicht
gelingt verlassen Sie die Koalition oder
regieren sie weiter es wird kommen so
wir wie jetzt die Verlängerung der
Atomkraftwerke auch stattgefunden hat so
wird auch die weitere Verlängerung
kommen weil die Grünen werden sich
diesen Realitäten nicht verstehen
Politik wenn sie jetzt sagen sie macht
Frau Scholz ist ein großer Erfolg aber
es reicht wenn die FDP die absolute
Mehrheit hätte wäre die Verlängerung wir
haben das leider nicht und deshalb ist
Politik auch eine Frage von Kompromissen
und heute ist ein guter Kompromiss
erstmal aber bestellen
in doch an man bei den Kompromissen ist
auch der Klima- und Umweltschutz und die
Umstellung auf die erneuerbaren Energien
ein WE wichtiger Punkt ich bitte dass
das nicht einfach unter Tisch fällt und
es geht
nicht nur um Atomkraftwerke und um
kohlekommissionen
nuklearte Energie ganz genau wir machen
einen kleinen Kampf ganz kurz
wir können nicht immer von heute auf
morgen plötzlich eine Krise da ist
irgendwie etwas einfach
sprudelt da nicht einfach
das vorbereitet sein internationale
dioxid Abschreibung
da muss man heute die Entscheidungen für
Treffen
das ist aber interessant von der
Playstation
natürlich
das ist ja völlig okay ich sage nur mal
im international Blick vielleicht ist
das ein Argument ich bin Präsiden
phantasienbrücke da ist auch Japan und
Korea drinnen die haben jetzt zweites
Quartal hintereinander beide ein sattes
Plus warum weil die Wirtschaft weiß man
setzt auf die Kernenergie um und das ist
die Argumentation dort die Klimaziele zu
erreichen um wieder an dieser Stelle die
Lage neu zu justieren und zu sagen wir
haben da einen Krieg da ist schwedischen
Gründe wir waren bei der Kernfrage hier
welche Politik eigentlich tatsächlich
Politik für die Bürger im Moment macht
das wirklich
die AFD erleben wir wieder ihre
ex-partei erlebt im Moment massiven
Zulauf zumindest jetzt wieder bei den
Landtagswahlen in Niedersachsen freuen
sie sich eigentlich über diese Stimmen
noch nein natürlich nicht also ich meine
ich bin ja vor sieben Jahren ausgetreten
aus der AFD und das ist nicht mehr
meiner Partei das sind ganz andere
Partei als die die ich mal gegründet
habe freuen sie ärgern sich darüber über
den Zulauf also ich finde es misslich
weil ich glaube dass dieser Zulauf aus
einem ganz anderen Gründer als aus
dieser energiepreiskrise der kommt denn
wenn es nur um die Energie das heißt
Krise ginge dann müsste ja eigentlich
der Zulauf zur Union kommen letzten
Endes die also ich meine in den
Energiefragen vertritt die Union er
praktisch dieselben Vorstellungen wie
die AFD das auch tut ja Kernkraftwerke
länger laufen lassen alle Angebote
nutzen und und ähnliche Dinge sondern
die AFD kriegt den Zulauf glaube ich
deshalb weil die Leute wissen die AFD
versucht einen Ausgleich mit Putin
hinzukriegen ja die dieses Putin
freundlich ne also die AFD betont die in
der Tat bestehende Gefahr dass dieser
Ukraine Konflikt sich ausweitet ja und
und das macht den gleichen und deshalb
und das ist so weiß ich nicht aus der
Flasche gelassen hat ich glaube
eigentlich putin hatte ihn aus der
Flasche gelassen aber
die die Sorge der der Bevölkerung oder
eines großen Teils der Bevölkerung ist
der dass dieser Konflikt nicht
beherrschbar wird das hier auf einer
eskalations-skala sind dass wir auf
einem sozusagen auf einer Rutsche
Rutschbahn sind die uns immer stärker in
diesen Ukraine Krieg hineinzieht
zuschauen dass die Leute dann irgendwie
etwas ganz anderes machen
Verfassungsschutz wegen Verdacht auf
Rechtsextremismus beobachtet wird ja
wenn das nicht wäre dann wird sie
wahrscheinlich eher zur
hauptpositionspartei passiert aber nur
in Maßen wie brisant wie hitzig würden
sie im Moment die Atmosphäre die
Stimmung im Land beschreiben wie
gespannt ich bin höchst besorgt vor
allem in Ostdeutschland
das ist jetzt überhaupt kein Vorwurf an
die Mitbürger in Ostdeutschland sondern
dort wird Protest aus einer
politikwissenschaftlichen Erklärung
könnte jetzt das untermauern stärker
emotionaler formuliert aber es hat
erstens natürlich mit der
wirtschaftlichen Lage der Angst davor
der Inflation
Rezessionsangst Energiekrise Preise
Arbeitsplätze auch das Thema Mittelstand
und gepaart auch mit dem Thema
Migration ist ja auch Thema der heutigen
Sendung
Migrationsbewegungen neues 2015 das
alles zusammen
produziert einen Protest für eine ich
sage rechtsextreme Partei die nicht
einmal an dieser Stelle Personen hat mit
dem man sich irgendwo hoffentlich nicht
identifiziert sondern eigentlich nur
eine Bewegung ist ein Ventil ist und ja
da haben wir als cdu/csu auch für
nachzuholen weil wir werden an dieser
Stelle nicht als die
Opposition wahrgenommen sie
Niedersachsen sondern der Protest
formuliert sich viel radikaler und das
macht mich schon betroffen in
Niedersachsen durchweg ob jetzt in
Städten oder auch am flachen Land
zwischen sieben und 12 13 14 Prozent
also wir haben da einen einen
Prozentanteil wo alle Parteien nicht nur
Tränendrüsen drücken und
betroffenheitsminen sondern wir müssen
uns auch um die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
an dieser Stelle kümmern und eine
Antwort geben und ich glaube dass wir da
schon gesagt haben und wenn Herr Lucke
AFD gegründet hätte wäre sicherlich noch
CDU Mitglied aber das wäre nur ein
frommer Wunsch sie haben das gerade
schon gesagt Herr scheuer inmitten
dieser tiefen Energiekrise gerade
corona-krise so ganz bisschen
abgefrühstückt scheint hinter uns zu
liegen ist aber noch nicht ganz tot mit
Blick auf Herbst und Winter kommt eine
neue Krise wieder hoch seit 2015 zwei 16
die höchsten Flüchtlingszahlen im
Muttermale sind damals zu uns gekommen
aus Syrien 2015 sind durch ein Foto ganz
berühmt geworden ihre persönliche
Geschichte durch ein selfie mit der
Kanzlerin was machen sie heute also mir
geht's erstes Mal schon viel besser als
2015 heute studiere ich ich bin am 15
Semester habe ich meine Studium schon
fast hinter mir studiere
wirtschaftskommunikationen der Berliner
HTW und mache gerade meine Praktikum bei
dir Deutsche Welle schon jetzt mein
dritter Monat und macht mir Spaß und es
geht mir schon viel besser und heute da
ich die Sprache erstmal gelernt habe ja
kann ich in der Gesellschaft schon
besser integrieren und verstehen es ist
keine
durchschnittsbiografie von all denen die
2015 2 16 zu ihnen gekommen sind also zu
uns gekommen sind also Durchschnitt was
war die Frage noch mal sie sind
überdurchschnittlich ja
durchschnittlich gut deutsch es ist eine
außergewöhnliche flüchtlingsbiographie
die meisten ist das bis heute nicht
gelungen also es hängt von Menschen ich
denke aber es ist mal ähm ich spreche
mich noch nicht so perfekt aber ich gebe
natürlich nur weil ich das will und das
betrifft Menschen die auch so innere
Motivation sag ich mal haben und wie wir
sehen viele Menschen haben auch die
Sprache gelernt also ich bin kein
Ausnahme sondern es gibt viele die das
auch geschafft haben also ich habe
vielleicht die Möglichkeit bekommen
nachdem ich dasselbe mit die
Bundeskanzlerin gemacht habe Menschen
kennenzulernen und das hilft natürlich
bei der Integration also man sollte
schon beide Seite schauen die
Integration läuft ja von beiden Seiten
von die Deutschen und von die Menschen
die aus aus dem Kriegsgebiet auch kommen
um hier Sicherheit zu haben ja also
jetzt haben sie auch deswegen so eine
ungewöhnliche Geschichte weil sie sich
heute für ukrainische Flüchtlinge
engagieren und weil sie verlobt sind mit
einer Frau die ihre Wurzeln in der
Ukraine hat genau also ich habe das
erste mal selber erlebt wie schwierig
ist das wenn man hier in den neuen Land
ist ich habe das alles so Schritte
erlebt neues im Land alles ist so
komplett neu und die Menschen brauchen
dringend Hilfe und das sind halt ja
Frauen mit Kinder dann bin ich bei der
rotes Kreuz ich habe die Situation näher
geschaut und ich mit meiner Freundin die
aus kommt auch sind wir unterwegs und
helfen ganz viele ukrainische Familien
die in Berlin leben und die brauchen
wirklich Hilfe die die sind ohne ihre
Partner dann hier gekommen und sind
traurig brauchen dringend Hilfe und es
am Anfang war die Bereitschaft da aber
ich sehe immer das ist immer weniger
wird was das nicht passieren durfte also
die Menschen sollen immer da sein
wirklich und vielleicht in eine
Unterkunft gehen die Situation da
schauen also die Menschen brauchen
Freunde sag ich mal die mit denen
unterhalten können weil wir das
möglicherweise erscheuer gar nicht
schaffen können inmitten dieser Krise
Tiefe Energiekrise wir haben gerade von
allen Seiten hier von freiengelenkäfer
von Herrn Lucke von Herrn Scheffler von
ihnen selbst gehört wie dramatisch die
Lage ist und jetzt haut eine neue
flüchtlingskrise dran und immer mehr
Menschen stellen die Frage ja Leute wie
soll das gehen verstehen sie das also
nur ein starkes Deutschland kann anderen
helfen und das ist anders wie 2015 da
kommt jetzt kommen jetzt zwei
Entwicklungen zusammen nämlich die die
mir im ersten Teil der Sendung
diskutiert haben und natürlich auch die
Angst und die Besorgnis in der
Bevölkerung und zum anderen natürlich
die Verantwortung für die vielen
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine wir
haben über eine Million bei uns
aufgenommen das ist zehnfach das was
Frankreich aufgenommen hat also wir
stellen uns wieder der Verantwortung
leider nicht zu viele in Europa und
jetzt kommt noch eine zweite und das
darf man nicht
übereinander legen über die Balkanroute
eine neue Migrationswelle die uns alles
abverlangt alles abverlangt und ich habe
Sorge dass das zum gesellschaftlichen
Sprengstoff wird aber auch zur
wirklichen ja
für unsere demokratischen Grundfeste
weil diese Überlagerung der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung der Sorgen
der Menschen und einer zusätzlichen
Migrationswelle eben nicht die
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine das
ist ein eine Melange gepaart und es der
Gedanke dazu oben drauf dass wir mit den
Koalition mit dem Koalitionsvertrag der
Ampel und den Vorkehrungen die vom
Bürgergeld angefangen bis zum
Spurwechsel zu sozialen Vergünstigungen
zu Bezugsmöglichkeiten
vieles Land gibt
in Europa macht und das wäre
lass uns einen Moment über die Situation
sprechen wie dramatisch ist die Lage
schon im Moment im Moment wenn wir keine
Energiekrise hätten vermutlich würden
wir ausschließlich über flüchtlingskrise
gerade berichten über sehr viele
Ukrainer die zu uns kommen aber auch
sehr viele die über die Balkanroute
wieder zu uns kommen die Zahlen sind da
dramatisch gestiegen es gibt
Alarmsignale von den Landräten vor allen
Dingen aus den Gemeinden wir können
einen Fall einmal aus Bayern zeigen der
uns aufgeschreckt hat in diesen Tagen
der kommt aus der Nähe von München ganz
genau bei Fürstenfeldbruck und da
entsteht ein ganz neuer Konflikt und das
nur weil die Landräte und die
Bürgermeister verzweifelt nach Platz
suchen für immer mehr ankommende
Flüchtlinge
ein Seniorenheim das nun auch zum
Flüchtlingsheim wird oberschweinbach
nordwestlich von München das
Seniorenheim am Klostergarten 2008
eingeweiht inzwischen 137 Plätze
bestens um sorgt so ist das Motto der
Einrichtung jetzt soll das Seniorenheim
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen 80 das komplette
Erdgeschoss wird zur
Flüchtlingsunterkunft wer jahrelang
unten sein zu Hause hatte musste raus
ins Obergeschoss umziehen wie Hannelore
Gärtner und Ursula Hellwig beide 83
Jahre alt beide mussten für die
ankommenden Flüchtlinge ihre Wohnungen
Räumen nun leben sie auf einem Flur mit
schwer dementen
es ist nicht so wie es mir vorgestellt
habe weil da ist ein Theater manchmal da
oben gell
die dem Menschen die schmeißen
das dahin alles Wasser der eine Holstein
Bipa drauf sind Puller dahinten und
alles so eine Sache
Pflegebedürftige die ziehen müssen um
Platz für Flüchtlinge zu machen zunächst
ukrainische auch bürgermeister Norbert
Riepel rechnet mit Konflikten es werden
Leute einziehen Kinder bis zu
Erwachsenen Herren mit unterschiedlichen
oder ganz anderen Lebensgewohnheiten und
Tagesabläufen als es eben
pflegebedürftige Personen in am Heim
haben und das wird insbesondere abends
aber auch tagsüber sehr viel Unruhe im
Heim selber im Gartenbereich oder auch
in den Nachbargärten verursachen die
Folge ein Wachdienst vier
Sicherheitsleute sollen das Heim nun
rund um die Uhr bewachen doch wer hat
all das entschieden der Bürgermeister
glaubt am Ende gings ums Geld das
Pflegeheim hat seit ein zwei Jahren hier
zwei Jahren Riesenprobleme Personal zu
finden
Pflegepersonal zu finden insofern wurden
Räume dann zwangsläufig mussten leer
gelassen werden und man hat jetzt
entschieden das Erdgeschoss zu räumen
und das dann extern zu vermieten um
einfach Ersatz Einnahmen zu generieren
ein Seniorenheim wird auch zum
Flüchtlingsheim und selbst der
zuständige Landrat weist jede Schuld von
sich er müsse eben immer neue
Unterkünfte bieten für immer neue
Flüchtlinge ich bekomme jede Woche 50
Menschen vor der Tür gestellt und muss
sie unterbringen und muss dafür sorgen
dass sie im Winter nicht erfrieren oder
verhungern und das muss ich tun und
deswegen muss ich notfalls auch zur
Beschlagnahme greifen natürlich nicht
von Häusern oder Wohnungen aber von
Gewerbeimmobilien oder ähnlichem wenn
sie leer stehen ein Landkreis am Limit
immer mehr Flüchtlinge und so müssen den
oberschweinbach nun sie Platz machen
Pflegebedürftige für Flüchtlinge
Herr scheuert dass es nah an ihrer
Heimat
Pflegeheimbewohner die jetzt umziehen
teilweise auch umziehen wollen aber
umziehen müssen um Platz zu machen für
Flüchtlinge weil der Landrat der
Bürgermeister einfach kein Platz mehr
haben ja weil wir untersprechen nicht
von den ukrainischen Kriegsflüchtlingen
sondern weil wir jeden Tag jeden Werktag
einen vierstelligen eine vierstellige
Zahl an Zugängen haben vor allem auch
zum ukrainische Flüchtlinge in dem Fall
nicht nur nicht nur erstmal um Ukraine
aber später zum Beispiel zum Beispiel
Zentrum in meiner Heimat sind 500 Plätze
aber 1500 Personen die jetzt
tagesaktuell darstellen ich habe noch
mehr nachgefragt
natürlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied
jetzt erstmal wenn die die Wohnung
verlassen müssen wegen eines Syrers oder
wegen eines sugarin erstmal relativ egal
okay ich kann jetzt den einen Fall nicht
beurteilen nur eins ist klar dass wir
dadurch zwei verschärfte Situationen
bekommen und wenn zum Beispiel andere
Nachbarstaaten Europa jetzt das auch
schon gelernt haben wie man Flüchtlinge
weiter schiebt nach Deutschland die
Österreicher verteilen Bahntickets dass
sie dann von der von der Grenze die
Obergrenze durchgekämpft aber wir sind
ja immer an der Regierung also das heißt
unser Grundprinzip war Steuern ordnen
und begrenzen und das ist auch heute
noch wir haben letzte Woche aber das
letzte Woche in Deutschland Bundestag
haben wir einen Antrag heute nur
Obergrenze mit ihnen eine
flüchtlingsobergrenze wir müssen jetzt
stoppen natürlich wir brauchen jetzt
natürlich auch für ukrainische
Flüchtlinge nein deswegen habe ich sehr
Unterschieden was ist die Unterschiede
die Unterscheidung nein Frau Engelke wir
waren uns einigen Stopp Stopp Stopp wir
waren uns einig EU aus jetzt lassen wir
mal Ukraine Krieg Weg EU-Außengrenzen
gilt für das Asylverfahren und des
Asylverfahren ist über Jahre nicht
europäisch geregelt worden die
Außengrenze gilt das Verfahren muss klar
sein aber diese jetzt
überhaupt diese Regierung machte
eigentlich den den falschen Dreh nämlich
pull-effekte noch zusätzlich durch das
Burger Geld zu machen jetzt passiert ist
das eine Personengruppen gegen eine
andere ausgespielt wird hier in diesem
Fall sind die Pflegeheimbewohner gegen
die Flüchtlinge die da reinkommen
es geht jetzt hier auch um reguläre
Migration also ich bin strikt dagegen
dass wir hier anfangen Obergrenzen
einzuführen die Diskussionen
sie leben doch auch in Europa
dafür gibt es keine Obergrenze das darf
auch nicht sein und
ich nicht
aber da und das zweite ist wie begründen
sie denn eine zwei Klassensituation von
Migrationen
gleich zurück mit einem Streit in dieser
flüchtlingskrise zurück hier bei Bild
bis gleich
[Musik]
mittendrin und zurück bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen und wir streiten in
dieser so tiefen Krise über eine neue
Krise die immer mehr dazu kommt die
flüchtlingskrise und andreas Scheuer ist
bei uns zu Gast und hat eben eine
Aufnahmestopp gefordert hier für alle
außer ukrainischen Flüchtlingen Frau
Engelke völlig dagegen der einzige am
Tisch der hier gerade mit regiert aktiv
ist von Schäffler
FDP-Bundestagsabgeordnete Aufnahme
stoppt jetzt sagt andreas Scheuer also
wir brauchen vor allem eine europäische
Regelung ja das machen
man kann nicht innerhalb Europas die
Grenzen abbauen oder haben sie recht es
wird auch gerade
außerhalb der oder an den
EU-Außengrenzen
hält man diese Grenzen nicht robust und
dafür haben wir ja frontext geschaffen
die letztendlich
alle anderen verschärfen
gerade über eine flüchtlingskrise und
wir verschieben das Problem
gerade auch mit eurem Paket sprechen
über eine neue flüchtlingskrise in dem
Jahr 2022 in diesem Herbst und Winter
wir haben die Zahlen vorliegen weit über
eine Million Flüchtlinge von denen die
meisten Ukrainer sind und wir sagen
Ukraine sind aber ausgenommen die sind
total willkommen können wir das dass die
Frage stellen sich im Moment ganz viele
Menschen können wir das mit Blick auf
den Herbst und Winter wo wir wissen
Franzosen haben zum Beispiel kaum
Flüchtlinge bisher aufgenommen aus der
Ukraine können wir die alle in
Deutschland aufnehmen wenn es noch mal
eine massive Fluchtwelle im Herbst und
Winter gibt aus der Ukraine das ist
natürlich immer eine Frage wie groß ist
diese Fluchtwelle aber im Augenblick
wird es nicht so als er das
unbeherrschbar ja da können wir uns das
leisten es ist ja so
wir müssen diese Fluchtbewegung aus der
Ukraine die wir im Februar März und
gehabt haben die ist ja auf eine
unglaubliche Bereitschaft in der
Bevölkerung gestoßen diese Leute privat
das hat der Moderne auch genauso
meine eigene Perspektive sagen diese
Bereitschaft ist nicht ausgeschöpft
worden also ich meine Frau und ich wir
haben das Angebot ich war wir haben zwei
mal einen Anruf gekriegt ist nie ein
Ukraine bei uns aufgekreuzt ja ich
glaube es gibt nach wie vor dieser
Aufnahmebereitschaft in der Bevölkerung
ukrainische das klar ja auch im
Privathaushalt sie wollten einen
Flüchtlingen aufnehmen aus der Ukraine
und das ist keiner gekommen keiner
gekommen war zu weit weg von Hamburg ja
oder Sie wollen Lucke nein nein nein
bestimmt nicht sondern soll es so dass
wir halt ein bisschen außerhalb von
Hamburg leben Winsen an der Luhe ja 30
km weg oder sowas und dann hieß es nein
wir sind schon in Hamburg und uns in die
Kinder schon eingeschult und da haben
wir medizinische Versorgung und unten
solche Sachen also die Leute waren sehr
sehr schnell irgendwo untergebracht
teilweise bei Freunden und Bekannten die
selbst aus der Ukraine stammen teilweise
bei Gastfamilien da meines Erachtens ist
es so dass die Aufnahmebereitschaft der
Bevölkerung nach wie vor enorm hoch ist
und dass da auch durchaus noch
Kapazitäten sind deshalb sehe ich bei
den ukrainischen Flüchtlingen im
Augenblick jedenfalls aber genau
wirklich für etwas die man nacheifern
soll dass man hier auf privates
Engagement
aber das scheint ja und zwar jeden Tag
das war jedes der Bürger sich engagiert
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen aber
bei mir so wir müssen sagen ja
ukrainische Flüchtlinge ich sage auch
dazu jeder muss wissen bei vollem
Leistungsbezug und auch die Möglichkeit
beispielsweise in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
gehen wenigstens für die Zeit ist dafür
ja voller Leistung
wir haben doch die Möglichkeit das haben
wir ja
migrationspolitische Sonderweg für die
andere Gruppe die ich meine also
Balkanroute heißt für die Ampel
Bleiberecht reduzieren
fachkräfteeinwanderung aufweichen
Familiennachzug erleichtern
chancenaufenthaltsrecht weichgestalten
Asylsystem unterlaufen
sie sagen Herrn Scheffler er sorgt dafür
dass die Zahlen weiter steigen ja
natürliche Ebene da eine stärkere Rolle
übernehmen muss das ist aus meiner ja
aber das ist der Punkt das ist doch eine
eine binnensicht entscheidend ist das
die Europäische Union an den Anfang das
ist Grenzen entsprechen ich dachte sie
sagen das ist eine Binse eine Binse ist
es nämlich auch und das sind die selben
Binsen die wir seit sechs oder sieben
Jahren haben und deshalb
ja haben sie völlig egal und genau
deswegen habe ich angefangen
genau darüber weil dieser Streit schon
so lange geht genau deswegen habe ich
mit dem österreichischen Ex-Kanzler mit
Sebastian Kurz über genau dieses Problem
besprechen und Sebastian Kurz erhebt im
Grunde dieselben Forderungen wie 2015
zwei 16 ich habe mit ihm über diese neue
flüchtlingskrise hier bei Bild
gesprochen
wenn man hier nicht gegensteuert wenn es
nicht schnell Druck von Seiten der
Europäischen Union gibt diese illegalen
Migrationsströme wieder zu stoppen dann
werden die Zahlen weiter massiv
ansteigen und wir werden in manchen
Ländern
nahe an das kommen was wir im Jahr 2015
oder 2016 erlebt haben ich glaube es
zeigt einfach dass seine Überforderung
des System gibt es zeigt das zu Recht
unsere Systeme nicht darauf
ausgelegt sind unbegrenzt Menschen
aufzunehmen ich habe nicht den Eindruck
dass Europa im Moment sehr gut gerüstet
ist ich glaube aber das ist
relativ einfach wäre da wieder einen
richtigen Weg einzuschlagen es ist aus
2015 und den Folgejahren eigentlich
bekannt was gemacht werden muss nämlich
nicht wegzusehen nicht das Problem klein
zu reden nicht
die Politik der offenen Grenzen zu
verfolgen sondern an den Außengrenzen
Menschen zu stoppen Schlepper konsequent
zu verfolgen und auch zu bestrafen
es ist eine Abrechnung mal eben kurz
dort von Österreichs Ex-Kanzler
Sebastian Kurz der im Grunde dieselben
Worte wählt wie 2015 2016 und das ist
das Bittere für alle hier in der Runde
dass diese Probleme bisher immer noch
nicht gelöst sind viel Stoff für eine
nächste Sendung zu genau diesem Thema
ich danke Ihnen allen freien Käfer Herr
Scheffler Herr mudermani Herr Steuer
unter Lucke danke Ihnen herzlich in
einen schönen guten Abend
[Musik]